[Music]
what's up kicks family it's boyd meets
back here again with our new debate show
sneaker swap where we argue a lot
you know i got the usual guys with me cj
christian jeff
gentlemen how are we doing yo man
topic for today if you had the travis
sky air jordan 4
would you trade it for the off-white air
jordan 4.
i want to hear i know this is tough this
is tough
i want to hear from my man jeff first
talk to me
oh man i gotta set it up all right cool
i've i've probably been labeled the
travis scott kicks hater
for the last couple of videos but
understand this is probably pound for
pound
my favorite one that he did i love the
color blue
i love the colorway i'm a wrestling fan
so you know cactus jack
is a one with me and it's just i'm not a
fours guy and those are the type of
fours that make me want to cop like a
million pairs of them
um i like i like some of the off-whites
but the fours like when i saw the fours
the off-white fours i was like yo
that's something that i would want to
cop but if you're talking about i had
the travis scots already
there's no way it's so versatile it just
looks
good it doesn't even look like a four if
that makes sense
it looks like it's its own alternate
reality version of the force but just
like even more
fire so yeah i can there's a there's a
bunch of other off-whites
that i could have other than those fours
the travis ones aren't the ones i'm
giving up for them okay i love that take
jeff
christian it's on you see fellas
i actually appreciate this trade for
once because this is actually the first
trade where i actually have these
sneakers
this is why we do it yeah this is the
first method he's doing he's going
method
bro this is the first shoot that we've
done so far the first finger spot where
i actually had this shoe
so all that being said if i had the
off-white
uh fours where i traded for the travis
scots i still am trading for the traffic
stop course i'm still doing it
um don't get it twisted i'll be there
just like y'all on saturday
ready to catch the sale same time same
place everything with it you know
but not like noticing back to the floors
all five fours but the travis golf
course is just that much better
jeff said that houston euler cut away
the suede on the top
and like i know we're not even talking
about it but bro that like friends and
family colorway the purple ones
don't give me that looks like this don't
even start already oh like
a lot of that and plus like technically
this is his first collab with jordan
brandon i mean like all respect to
the air force ones with nike and all
that but
this is probably his first this was his
first one and
arguably the one that set him up for
like where he is in the sneaker culture
right now
and i honestly think it's his best shoe
with like jordan brand you know like
travis scott floors
scott jordan ones wow i think not the
ones
wow maybe it's a hot day i don't know
but like that's wow
that's a decent take bro that's a decent
take cause those traffic the ones are
fire fire but i get it i i get it
i i get it okay
i i first of all i just want to say
bravo to everyone for not making a
sink we made it four minutes without
making a single virgil joke
they're coming i know they're coming but
i just want to now
acknowledge it i wanna i want it to ramp
up but uh
i love listen i i actually like both
sneakers
all disrespect aside from virgil um
these are these are some of my favorite
off-whites
uh on the four i didn't like the four is
for me is such an iconic silhouette and
when the travis came out i was like
that's the way you do that's the way you
do a new take on the four
because that blue is classic they did go
with everything
but this off-white four the cream
colorway like
i don't know if you guys are like gum
soul fanatics like me this is like if
the gum sole was the whole shoe
but all that being said so i pick off
white fours
but i don't know if virgil will ever see
this the deconstructed look
this is your last one like
it's not it's run dry he like go out on
a high note it's these
it's the off-white fours he did a good
job on these that cream colorway goes
with everything but
i don't know you got it you got to
change it up a little bit virgil cj i
need you to come home this is his best
off-white shoe you said that's you heard
it here i
shout out to another guy on the br kicks
team who gave me the other again i i
have hot takes on the off-white line
but the hyper dunks are the only other
off-whites i like
okay with the strap i just it seems like
there are real work
done a real virtual take on these
on these silhouettes and yeah i think
that it's one of the best i've seen
well i just want to get to a point where
i could make something
and write the actual name of what it is
thousands of millions of dollars like
that's a stun like
joke on them all you want but my man
literally writes the color of the
sneaker on the sneaker
it sells thousands of dollars like he's
he's for
he's done it he's found the loop he
didn't reinvent the wheel he
wrote wheel on the wheel thousands of
dollars
you can't hate on that you can't all
that just that like i said i guess
that's fashion
bro uh you guys already know how i'm
rocking big cactus jack
travis is the one everything every
sneaker that he's touched
is a banger it's a hit just like his
tracks
his sneakers are hits cj i think you
made a great point
virgil did a really good job the cream
colorway is good
but i feel like i've seen this somewhere
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna name names
but i've seen this somewhere
i think travis always brings uh a unique
vision for his shoes
it's always something we have we've
never seen like you're saying the blue
on the four the reverse suits on the
ones the stash on the sixes
travis is doing it a little differently
i think he's thinking on a higher plane
than virgin right now a higher player i
didn't say that
i agree with him i i think he's thinking
on a higher plane than virgil right now
100 wait me so you're telling me you
would take
travis is like what top three top five
shoes over virgil's top three top five
yes yes i'm taking if we're if all right
what's virgil's top three hold on
there's the top three
exactly we're gonna say the presto i
think the prestos chicago's chicago ones
serena's their maximum let's not include
let's not include up there
oh we can't include the jordan this has
to be a nike jordan thing okay i don't
know
including all of it boy okay presto's
chicago ones and what's the last one
oh i like those fives a little bit out
the recent ones
i would say his first air force one was
heat
okay oh yeah yeah yeah
yes but how it's really hard to mess up
an air force one even though nike has
been doing that
i'd add a random air bubble but and
again
inspired by virgil i feel like the
deconstructed look
but i will say he did it perfectly that
in the air max one i feel like the black
air max ones
were pretty dope but i mean yeah i'm
definitely taking uh travis's top three
over virgil's top three hundred percent
do you see do you see the hat i'm take
like because we're gonna we're gonna do
the force
right yeah we'll do the blue colorway
yeah we're definitely going to do the
ones
all right ones in the chicago's they
they they they bounce out
yeah i'll give you that okay what about
those yellow suede sixes that haven't
been released
i don't know if we could do that yet
since it's not out yeah can't do again
those would win everything okay are the
fours and the presto's awash
that's tough i don't know i think i'm
taking the fours over the prestos
i'm taking the force of the prestos yeah
i'm not oppressed those guys so
yeah i was going to say the same thing
like i'm not i'm not a press dog so it
may not be fair but
it's i don't see a lot of things beating
those fours bro
yeah but like we don't have to
necessarily talk about the blue color
which is also the purple
i mean if if we're gonna talk about
something to beat those travis fours we
could talk about the doernbechers
those supernovas
let's not get it twisted them kids are
better designers than some of these
other
designers that get paid thousands of
dollars them kids have put out heat
yes and i hope that they raise all the
money that they can for that hospital
they get over
all their ailments and they're able to
heal and they get into some type of
design
something some type of arts because
jordan brand needs to hire them
who is the most influential person
on jordan brand's roster designer
you're saying rappers athletes
i don't know who could beat him michael
travis scott
listen travis did travis in the last
few years probably yeah he revived the
brand yes for sure
yes for sure because i mean i would say
i mean jordan brand good year for them
because
travis being involved obviously the last
dance like
people have seen the jordan highlights
that has that's helped i've seen general
release jordan ones now cost
800 bucks i just wanted you to try to
get the jordan 1 storm blues
they're 800 right now those were like
hidden twitter deal accounts back in the
day
and now i'm like i'm not paying a resale
for a white and blue colorway that
jordan won
but i would say yeah travis is
influential and he saved
brand a little available shoes are still
going to move
but if he left the brand is he taking
jordan brand with it
let's say he left and jordan brand would
still be jordan brand they still could
put out whatever colorways or whatever
i think you i think you can't take away
the fact that he
elevated the entire sneaker game because
if he wasn't michael jordan those
sneakers wouldn't move
to begin with okay and then if we talk
about
yes we'll have to put team jordan over
here for a second
right if we talk about the ones that
that move on
average what travis what's travis's clip
once every 18 months or something like
once every
12 months he puts out one yearly yes
yeah okay
so in one year he has one line
but jordan brand may drop four or five
new colorways retro colorways that are
gonna move
so if we're talking about actual if
we're talking about money
then jordan by default is more important
if we're talking about
design and fresh takes then i would say
travis because they're not they're not
doing what travis is doing
in terms of innovation to the actual
colorways
i guess we're talking right now like
where the energy is like
i'll take a step further honestly i
think rappers in general the most
important thing to the sneaker game
period
like if you're thinking of travis you
have drake you have kendrick lamar
you have kanye exactly pharrell even
like
i don't even know who g-dragon was asap
you know i'm saying so like they're the
most important thing to this game
they're pushing the energy in general so
that's where it is i will say though
guys
do not cross michael jordan you saw
10 hours of reasons why not so
i'm saying it comes down to if travis
left the brand
jordan has a bag full of tricks
it is separate you can go to a supreme
you can go to another artist
like that that's the scary like jordan
brand whoever is behind it whether it's
jordan himself like
they will figure out the new travis
scott unfortunately
but that's what that's why all respect
to kanye because he challenged nike
and was like it's me this is it's all on
me
and so we went to adidas and he he did
his own thing and look at where we're
now you know
jordan brand needs a lot of these
collaborations
to kind of stay relevant and like even
going back to
the off-white fours in general and jeff
you mentioned the doormaker 4 is like
the reason why i think the off y4s
aren't even there well
they're there but like not the traffic
sports because like there's just better
jordan four collapsed in general like i
think the cause jordan four is better
the length guys one it might be better
even the undefeated fours might be
better really
you can keep those marky mark we do not
need your fast food collab
force i mean i'll take the flip them
i'll flip them like yeah he'll flip them
to jimmy
that's saying a lot though that is
saying a lot because like
those uh virgil fours are fire
so so to say that it's just showing the
quality of the four the
fours might have some of the best
collabs out of all the jordans now that
i'm thinking about it like now that i
sit here and think
like that's saying a lot like i it's
it's almost like
how if if you lost
a battle rap to daylight when he went
off in his recent battle
right what you gonna say you tip your
hat like he he went off somebody goes
off it's like oh i lost two
i lost to a goat i lost to a legend if
michael jordan beats me one-on-one
in basketball what are y'all really
gonna say to me i don't do this for a
living
if i scored once that's my championship
so to to
measure virgil's fours up against those
other fours it's just showing how
important like christian is saying those
collabs are man because you take those
away and it's
you know how many times am i gonna buy
the the breads i may buy them a lot
but still how many times can i actually
buy them and i really need them
um so back to the topic of virgil uh i
want to bring this together our next
question
who's done more for their respective
brands travis scott for
jordan virgil for nike virgil did more
for his brand in general just because of
like taking
what he did with off-white in general
and flipping it with nike and jordan and
flipping into lv
like that's a that's a crazy kind of
flip i don't know how you do that so
i mean all jokes inside i guess are like
that's
that's kind of that's very impressive so
travis is still working on his collabs
all loved him in the shoes but
definitely virgil i think has done more
for his brand as
a whole i i know i picked the virgil's
off the off white fours up top but i
think travis has
at least had more fun and gave it a
little bit more variety with his
his versions you know again it's like
for every single collab he's done
he's come up with like almost a premise
you know it's like
upside down swoosh it's that little
pocket on the sixes like
i appreciate that creativity now
again virgil he has really unlocked that
deconstructed look but
i don't i haven't seen much modifying
that or toying with it
as it evolves so i would have to go
travis in terms of like
evolved and like really done something
with with his uh
sort of opportunity i don't know if the
average sneaker friend
knew or sneakerhead knew who
virgil was as opposed to knowing who
travis was so virgil coming in as a
designer
hip-hop and and sneaker culture have
been inextricably linked they're one in
the same they've grown from the same
actual culture of graffiti and and music
and and art and all of that right
they've grown from the same
same uh foundation correct so
for a rapper to come in and make a fire
collab with a sneaker
company i'm almost expecting that okay
so i i don't know if i'm expecting
somebody from the fashion world
to make a sneaker that i would want like
that i think is gonna be fire off top
because they may go
left and i say you know that's not
that's not how i roll
so i think in terms of their own
personal brand virgil
expanded to a whole nother part of the
culture
but in terms of what they actually did
for the brands that they created
i think i think it kind of evens out man
i think travis
travis was more surgical with it
where it was specific sneakers and he's
and he's putting his all into that as
opposed to virgil having the breath
of all of the different types he didn't
just stick with jordan he did
nike too right right oh and he he had
one style
across all sneakers as opposed to unique
styles across a few sneakers
yeah so i think i think it's kind of i
think it's personal preference in terms
of what they've done for the brand
either way
nike and jordan i guess we should just
say nike just they've been caking bro
so you know we were talking about
trading the travis scott uh air jordan
fours
for the off-white air jordan forest can
you guys uh let's go around and tell me
what is your favorite uh air jordan 4
collab
i don't say undefeated like i don't i
just i i think undefeated does a great
job with anything they touch
um been a big fan of theirs for a long
time uh
it goes with everything um and obviously
the four is just a beautiful silhouette
i would definitely go undefeated
my favorite all right i'm gonna cop out
my favorite jordan 4 collab
is either the travis scott jordan force
or the college jordan four those are the
two fire jordan four collabs i've ever
seen so
yeah i gotta go i gotta go i was gonna
say the undefeateds that colorway
is ju literally undefeated but the cause
yeah what the material the thing about
cause
collabs are always the it looks quality
yeah
and like you got that nice what is it
suede and then like the
little like laser details almost like
the gray and black ones those are
you can yeah if i had to pick two shoes
to have my collection only those
i could i could live with the cause
fours
i think um for me it's it's the
doernbecher fours
those are the ones that i i always
wanted to have
i'm the type of person that i like
stories behind the sneakers and i like
the individuality of the artist to
shine and be exhibited on the sneaker
and for it to be
a young kid young kid in the hospital
that's making these to raise money
like you can't beat that and also the
subtle
the subtle and it's really overt too but
looking at the design how it's all black
with the superman logo and then the
green
kryptonite like surrounding the
surrounding the sneaker that you see so
much through it
and like i said before man these kids
these kids are designers all right like
their creativity it feels like you give
them a blank canvas
and you're gonna get an all-time sneaker
and those are some things that i would
wear proudly just because of what it
represents
and it's just fire and i'm and as y'all
can see
i love comics you know what i'm saying
so why not
why not